hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today my interests a
question from one of my face book
readers jackeline who wrote in asking
about for mary kay business so she wrote
in saying i want to succeed that my mary
kay business which had been known for
three years I feel like I'm at a
standstill I work to other jobs I'm a
clerk at UPS been there for 17 years and
I'm a supervisor at a closing store for
12 years I've barely bring home five
hundred dollars a week and I need to
change I need to make more than
somebody's employee can you help me what
do i do so thanks for the question
jackeline really tough situation I know
a lot of a lot of people go through that
and a lot of entrepreneur struggle to
get their business off the ground and
it's great that you're sticking with it
I think a really good way to start off a
businesses to do a part-time so you're
still making some money from part-time
jobs so you can make sure you're making
forward progress every day on your
business and that's that's really key
that you're taking steps every day to do
something for your business now for your
mary kay company the biggest thing for
you and for any entrepreneur money you
have to provide more value and that's
rule number one for for you know making
money as an entrepreneur you have to
provide a lot of value you want to make
more money quickly provide more value
quickly alright that's going to be the
key so if you're not making a lot of
money with your business yet you're not
providing enough value to your clients
or potential clients so then I send it
up with you or the nachbar and repeat
orders from you because if they don't
see the value so that's where you have
to overcome with education and service
and you provide amazing value to them
and hopefully it's with the mary kay
business because there are people who
have had success with it so it can be a
model that works hopefully it's when it
works for you and you have to tie you in
your passion and your story into the
business why do you love Mary Kay and
why do you use their products and how
have they helped you become the person
that you are why are you so proud of
using it and that story will help
encourage people I guess to use it as
well when I do my promotion the market
is all about my story and everything
talk about in these videos and all the
work that I do is based on stuff that
I've used and I find value with that I
say how I use it and people tune into
that if I try to pitch something to say
hey this is great it's going to change
your life but I don't have any personal
connection with it then people won't buy
it right people have a pretty good BS
detector and you know they see somebody
promoting something that they don't
actually use it they don't find value in
themselves then you're not going to
convince them to buy right if you don't
really love it then they're not going to
love it that it's not going to show and
people are going to you know say that if
BS so again you got to find ways to send
out with the value got to provide more
value to your potential clients so that
they'll want to buy more from you second
step here then is over deliver think
about the serious you provide so with
Mary Kay you always have your specific
products that you're selling you want to
go above and beyond that over deliver
like crazy on the service especially at
the beginning to get people used to
using a product and support them through
any challenges they may have with using
a product so they may buy something that
you know you say is going to you know
solve whatever problem they're facing
they may not understand how to use it
properly they may be applying it
incorrectly and they get frustrated with
it you want to be there to provide
encouragement helped support and be the
person that is the the beauty expert
right you want to make them feel
confident and proud and look good and
that goes above and beyond just selling
them products and so you want to be that
person who provides that extra surface
so what happens that they're going to
want to buy more products from you right
if they really like how you've helped
them with one product they're more
likely to want to buy more products from
you they're also going to tell their
friends about you if they start looking
really good the friends going to say oh
you know why do you look so good well I
started using these Mary Kay products
from you right and so these are getting
some referral business and so that
happens from over delivering on the
service so you get people to buy more
buy more frequently and get more
referrals and it's not immediate it's
not a quick snap in and here you go
you've got you know a ton of new
business but it does come in and it
builds and it keeps building and you
want to incorporate that into every
customer relations
that you you have so that's one and two
the third thing I would suggest is to
model success I'm a huge believer model
success is why we created the website
the start was modeling famous
entrepreneurs I think there's a lot of
lessons you can learn from modeling
success you can look at the story of
Mary Kay we have it on the site you may
have also want to look at madam CJ
walker who was the first woman
billionaire in America and she started
similar beauty kind of products and
built it through a multi multi level
marketing network so that may help you
but I'd also look at people within your
own organization so Mary Kay has a lot
of people who are successful and is
there a way for you to be able to pick
their brain and you know ask them a
couple questions when you poach these
people you don't want to you know say
will you be my mentor because that's
implying a huge relationship that people
aren't willing to jump into if they
don't really know you so you want to
just say can I pick your brain can ask
you a few questions if there's somebody
local can you take them out to coffee
can you you know ask them just to answer
a few questions while they're walking to
a meeting while they're walking to their
car just try to get on their radar
screen and sit down with them and
they'll tell you a little bit of the ins
and outs and what worked for them and I
find that by malin success it it gives
you two things it gives you specific
strategies to say here's what I did that
was successful and hopefully will work
for you too but also gives you the
motivation to keep going because a lot
of these people it was hard like the
beginning was really hard if you look at
a successful entrepreneur it wasn't just
made overnight there was a lot of
hardship and pains that they had to go
through and just hearing about that at
least for me I found gives me the
motivation to keep going rights if you
go through you know really dark days you
find that you think you're never going
to make it through knowing that others
before you have had to face with similar
challenges and they got through just
gives you the extra motivation to keep
going so that helps again we're looking
at how do you provide a lot more value
to your customers how can you over
deliver like crazy and then how can you
model success both within the Mary Kay
franchise and then also outside to other
famous entrepreneurs and other
entrepreneurs who respect
hopefully that helps you get you know to
where you want to be keep going make
sure you're taking those steps every day
those of you who are watching the video
if you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more of these videos for you and if you
have a question about this video or
question about your own business feel
free to leave it in the comments below I
always read those and I try to respond
as many as I can so thank you and we'll
see you on the next episode
you